if i was your son  and i'm starting a business what advice  would you give me i would look at  everything that you're interested in and  the first piece of advice i'd give you  is do something around that for example  let me reverse this on you what do you  love besides business and things that  nature karate  great so to me karate would be a very  interesting thing to look at so what  would that be should we start a karate  fashion brand do we want to make karate  content we want to make a little karate  figurine and sell it on ebay we would  reverse engineer karate we would lay out  10 15 things you could do then i would  let you pick it because i'd want it to  be your decision  and then you'd roll